[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi and welcome
to episode number 131
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark Mandel and I'm here
with my colleague, as always,
Melanie Warrick.
How are you doing, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
doing good, Mark.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm all right.
But we're not physically in the
same place, which makes me sad.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Not today, but we
are both still in San Francisco.
MARK MANDEL: That is true.
That is true.
So we have some cool
stuff happening today.
MELANIE WARRICK: We do.
So who are we speaking with?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we're
speaking with fellow Googler,
Mandy Chan.
Super excited, wanted to have
them on the podcast for ages.
She is a fellow Googler
who works on the Actions
on Google team.
So lots of sounds and
voice stuff today.
Should be really good.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's very
applicable for a podcast.
Well, before we get
into our interview,
as always, we have our
cool things of the week
and we also have our
question of the week.
And this week's
question is, "I want
to push a Docker image to Google
Container Registry via Docker
Push.
So how can I set things up so
that I don't have to use gcloud
Docker -- push every time?"
And that will be a question
you'll find out at the end.
But as always, we're
going to start out
with the cool
things of the week.
And this week we
want to kick it off
by mentioning that Google
just published AI ethics,
and specifically it's
got a blog out about AI
at Google and our principles.
And so these principles
in particular,
you can read them at the link
that we'll include in our show
notes, as always.
But I'm just going to
highlight the seven key ones
and they are be
socially beneficial,
avoid creating or
reinforcing unfair bias,
be built and tested for safety,
be accountable to people,
incorporate privacy
design principles,
uphold high standards of
scientific excellence,
and be made available
for uses that accord
with these principles.
And one little note is
that that second one,
avoid creating or reinforcing
unfair bias, that was actually
specifically developed by a
team that Margaret Mitchell was
working with.
And Margaret
Mitchell, of course,
is somebody we interviewed
back in February in regards
to machine learning
bias and fairness.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
no, that's great.
And it's worth noting as well,
there's a follow-on article
from Diane Greene,
CEO of Google--
[INAUDIBLE] also
in the show notes--
it's talking about specifically
how Google's AI principles will
be effecting Google
Cloud, and how we'll
be using those in Google Cloud.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Mark, you got anything else?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I want to talk
about a great article
that has come out
of the Etsy engineering team.
I'm probably going to
massacre this name.
It says it's posted by Toria--
I'm going to say--
Toria Gibbs.
They have an article that
talks about basically
how they have their deployment
continuous integration
system deploying to a Google
Kubernetes Engine instance,
as well as their on-prem
Kubernetes instance.
So they basically
take you all the way
through setting up the
Jenkins infrastructure
and the whole
deployment pipeline,
and the build pipeline.
So it's definitely
worth reading.
It's a really cool article.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
MARK MANDEL: Also, call
out to the Etsy crew--
if you ever want to come on
the podcast, give us a holla.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, it would
be nice to actually get Etsy
on and talk through this, too.
Well, another cool
thing of the week--
and this is actually referenced
in the AI ethics list--
there's a couple of
students who are here
in California who've
decided to build out
a machine learning tool so they
can help predict wildfires.
Last year, not even just
the summer, in California
alone we had-- what was it?
9,000 fires burning,
approximately--
MARK MANDEL: It was pretty bad.
MELANIE WARRICK: --2,200
square miles of forest.
Yeah, it was really bad.
So they basically
designed a device
using TensorFlow machine
learning to visually assess
where there might be
potential fire hazards,
and specifically brush that
it may be so dry that it would
lead to the start of a fire.
So they've implemented
these devices in the forest
and have shown about
89% accuracy rate.
And we'll include the link in
the show notes-- really cool.
And they have a nice
video on this, as well.
Another cool thing of the week
that we wanted to mention--
and it's not as much
of a cool thing,
but it's an important thing--
google.org right now is
actually matching donations,
they are collecting
money and distributing it
to charities that are helping
with Puerto Rico's continued
recovery.
This of course, being
the continued recovery
from September 2017's
hurricane that hit Puerto Rico
and has severely
impacted the island.
So if you are still looking to
have a further impact in terms
of helping the recovery
efforts, if you donate money
before the 20th, Google is
matching up to $2 million
of the donation.
And 100% of what you
donate is actually
going to the different
charities that Google
is distributing these funds
to for the recovery efforts.
The only fees that
potentially could happen
is if you're out of
the country and there's
some kind of fee for
conversion of currency.
But outside of that, everything
is going to recovery efforts.
So if you wanted to donate,
you still want to donate,
please check it out.
We'll include the link
in the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
That's really, really cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Got announced very
recently, actually
I'm really excited about this.
So we're introducing
sole-tenant nodes
for Google Compute Engine.
So basically this is
cool because generally,
when you're using
Compute Engine,
we're essentially multi-tenant.
So there's a lovely
visualization
that sits on the
blog post that we'll
link to about how
basically you can have
multiple VMs on a
single physical machine,
and we manage all that for
you with live migrations
and all that kind of stuff.
Sometimes though that's not a
ideal scenario for whatever it
is you're building.
Maybe there's certain
compliance and regulation
that you're required to comply
with that means that you have
to be on a physical
machine that's only
and solely operated by you,
or solely tenanted by you,
and that might be a thing.
Or maybe you run a workload
that is super fine-grained,
so any kind of noisy
neighbor type situation
at a very, very
low level could be
potentially a problem for you.
I'm thinking particularly
in the gaming space
if you run dedicated
game servers.
I'm looking at all of you folks.
So yeah, but we're excited to
announce the beta availability
of sole-tenant nodes.
So basically you're the
only one on the hardware.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
they include in the notes
how easy it is to start it up
as well as a link to pricing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so that's
all available and ready
for you to play with now.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
Mark, I think it's time for
us to go talk with Mandy.
MARK MANDEL: So super excited
to have someone in the studio
that I met a long
time ago actually,
Mandy Chan, who is the
development community
manager for Actions on Google.
Mandy, thank you so much
for joining us today.
MANDY CHAN: Happy to be here.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
Thank you.
Super excited to have you here.
I know you've had a long and
varied history with voice
and working with this platform.
But before we get
stuck into that,
can you tell us a little
bit about who you are?
What do you do here at Google?
What's your background?
MANDY CHAN: Sure.
So I like to say that
I'm voice-aholic.
I love this space.
So when these things
first came out,
I would open a bank account just
to try the voice application
from a bank.
I would get a Domino's
pizza to order pizza,
also got a Fitbit to just
try the voice applications.
So that's how obsessed
I am with this space.
MELANIE WARRICK: You're very
passionate about this space.
MANDY CHAN: Yeah.
And I've built many
voice applications,
and doing the process
of building those voice
applications I got
frustrated with SSML.
And if you don't
know what SSML is,
SSML is a Speech
Synthesis Markup Language.
I created an open-source
project called SSML-Builder
to help the voice developers
to make building SSML easier.
So that's who I am.
And now that I'm at Google, I am
the developer community manager
for the Action on Google team.
And my role is to engage
with the developers
by creating practical
tools and content.
Basically, improving
the developer experience
is my goal.
Recently, I worked with my team
to build two Codelabs, level
one and level two.
So feel free to try that
and give us feedback.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So for those who've
never worked with
SSML, what exactly
is Speech (GARBLED) Synthesis?
[HONK]
Uh, I can't say the
word, but I'm close.
Anyways, Speech
(GARBLED) Synthe--
[HONK]
yeah, this is going
to be a fun one.
Markup language, what
exactly does that mean?
What does SSML actually
mean, specifically
for somebody who's
never used it before?
MANDY CHAN: A metaphor that I
like to give to people who are
technical or people who might
not be technical is basically--
for people who are technical,
it's a markup XML--
Extensible Markup Language.
And if you are web
developers and you know HTML,
HTML is the markup
language for the browser.
You markup the text.
And for SSML, it is
the markup language
to give style to the voice.
And I like to say that
the synthesizer is
like the browser for HTML.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
That's very helpful.
MARK MANDEL: So what kind of
things can you do with SSML?
MANDY CHAN: You can do a
lot of things with SSML.
So when we speak,
sometimes we pause.
So if you want the smart system
to take a break and pause--
sometimes pause can mean
hesitations, suspensions.
So you can put a
brake tag to pause.
And you can also, for
a number like 625,
it can be June 25th as a
date, or it can be fraction.
There's many different
ways to express numbers.
And also one of my favorite
SSML tag is called Prosody.
And you can change your voice
by manipulating, adjusting
the pitch, the
volume, and the speed.
So I know that in this
space we emphasize
on giving a persona for
your voice application.
And this is how SSML can
help you create a persona.
MARK MANDEL: I think you
have a demo, don't you?
MANDY CHAN: Yes, I do.
I do.
So let me show you guys
how we can create a persona
by adjusting the Prosody tag.
MELANIE WARRICK: And this
is Action on Google, right?
MANDY CHAN: Yes.
I'm actually just playing
the SSML tag in our Action
on Google console simulator.
So this Action on
Google is the platform
that we provide for the
third party developers
to build action for
the Google Assistant.
And what is action?
Action is-- I like to use
another metaphor-- it's
the verb that helps people get
things done, turn on the light,
you turn on the TV,
all of these are verbs.
And Action makes our
life more productive
and just makes your
everyday life easier.
And let me now demo SSML in the
Action on Google simulator--
how powerful that is.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Hello.
[BOING]
With SSML you can make
speech fast or make it slow.
(HIGH PITCHED) You can
make it high. (LOW PITCHED)
Or you can make it low.
You can make it loud. (QUIETLY)
Or you can make it quiet.
Or all three things at once.
But first, you can make me
spell colors like blue--
B-L-U-E. Edit this
to try yourself.
MANDY CHAN: So this is
just a very basic demo
of how SSML can give your voice
application a personality.
And if we add some audio
tech, like for Action
on Google Platform we
have a sound library that
has all kinds of fun sounds,
like animal sounds or windows
cracking sounds,
different sounds
that you can add to
your voice applications.
And for movie, if you
don't have background music
it won't be the same.
And same thing for
the voice application.
You want to add the
atmosphere, the mood,
and give the app
some personality.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
you can do this with--
you said, with
Actions on Google.
And this can be used for any
voice application, so anything.
It could be used with Assistant,
it could be used with--
MANDY CHAN: Other
platforms, too.
Yes.
MARK MANDEL: So
what sort of things
are you seeing people do
with these voice actions?
MANDY CHAN: Many
developers, they
have built actions for games.
That's a pretty
popular category.
And they also build for
the home automations.
I'm still looking
forward to what's
possible that other
developers can build.
But right now,
games and smart home
are the big two categories.
And one of the games that I
can also demo and show you
is called MixLab.
And let me demo
this from Action.
So this action
basically allows you
to mix different musical
instruments together just
using your voice command.
So (INTO SIMULATOR)
give me a dreamy guitar.
[GUITAR MUSIC PLAYING]
And I can add layer to it.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
MANDY CHAN: So this is just
one of the many ways that--
the creativity and the
imagination is unlimited.
It's all up to developers and
I'm really looking forward
to what the crazy, amazing
stuff that the developers can
do with our platform.
MELANIE WARRICK: What's
something you've built with it?
MANDY CHAN: Good question.
So the first voice
application I built
is called [INAUDIBLE] Speech.
And I'm a strong
believer to build
applications that help people.
And [INAUDIBLE] Speech
is a voice application
that helps people who speak
English as a second language
to improve their pronunciation.
Because I was born and
raised in Hong Kong,
English is my second language.
And growing up, I had
this electronic dictionary
to learn how to speak English.
And when I discovered
smart assistant,
it's like an entire
new world to me.
I have the environments
here-- every day
I'm forced to speak English.
For people overseas, they
don't have the environments.
So think about how much we can
do for people overseas if we
have more educational actions.
They can use this to
help their children
or help people who have autism--
different ways that people
can use smart assistant
to learn different things.
MELANIE WARRICK: I like
that point just because--
I remember when I was trying
to learn another language.
And when you don't have someone
to engage with who also--
and even if you did, if
they make you feel small
when you're trying
to engage with them,
it makes you less
interested in continuing
to pursue that language.
And that's why they
keep saying children
can learn more easily
in other languages
just because people are
more patient typically.
Technology or a
computer, it doesn't
have emotions in the game.
That's so great that
that's what you worked on.
MANDY CHAN: Yes.
I still want to see more
actions that focus on this area.
Google focused on the
system, get things done,
helping people make their
lives more productive.
I believe that education is the
untapped area for this space.
MARK MANDEL: That's amazing.
So from a developer
perspective, if somebody
is like, oh, this
sounds really cool
and I want to build an
action, what tools--
what stuff have we got
available for them to do that?
MANDY CHAN: So we have Action
on Google Platform, that's
the place that you
should go first.
And also, as I
mentioned earlier,
our team recently just
published two Codelabs.
Level one and level two is
absolutely beginner level.
You can quickly start building
Action on Google from scratch.
And Dialogflow is
another platform
that helps people who might
not even know how to code--
that you can build
an action quickly.
So let me explain how
Dialogflow and Action on Google
work together.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds great.
MANDY CHAN: So Dialogflow
provides a intuitive graphical
user interface to create
conversational experience.
You program in few example
sentences of things
that a user might
speak, and then you
can also specify what values
you need to get from the user.
It then uses machine learning
to understand the sentences
and manage the conversation.
The key part here is
that you no longer
need to process the
raw strings, Dialogflow
will handle that for you.
Basically all the heavy lifting,
Dialogflow does it all for you.
So that's how Action on Google
and Dialogflow work together.
And other than
that, our team also
created some amazing
templates for people
to build Action on Google
without coding experience.
In fact, at I/O when I
gave a demo at the Sandbox,
I met a couple of teachers.
They stopped by the booth,
and they were so excited
that I can create
tools for my students
to learn interactively
by using Action
on Google and Dialogflow.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: If I--
say I'm a programmer and I
want to create an action.
As human, I'm going to code
something to make that happen.
And then how do I make that code
do a thing, like, I don't know,
turn on my lights--
[LIGHT SWITCH CLICK]
--or open my garage
or something?
[GARAGE OPENS]
MANDY CHAN: So for devices we
have this Google Assistant SDK.
But for voice
application that we
can use with the Google
Home, the speaker alone,
as well as the phone,
we have this Action
on Google client library.
So I recommend developers go
to our documentation's page
to learn all the new
terminologies and concepts,
and how to create
your own fulfillments.
The fulfillment basically
is the business logic
that your actions can
do, can get things done.
MARK MANDEL: There's
some connections,
I think, to Firebase functions
or something like that.
MANDY CHAN: Yes.
Yes.
So great questions.
So our team highly recommend
developers to use Firebase.
Basically you just run the
command line, firebase init,
and then you can use the
function, the Firestore,
the database, and hosting--
everything in one place.
You can create your
action very quickly.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
And there's integration
there between actions and--
MANDY CHAN: And Firebase, yes.
MARK MANDEL: Lovely.
MELANIE WARRICK: Where
do you see SSML going?
MANDY CHAN: SSML is a standard.
And it means that there's
multiple communities
or companies, they have
to agree on this standard.
And I think the
direction right now
is really going to where the
synthesized voice will become
as good as professional actors.
Like, at Google I/O we announced
that there are six voices
coming up for Google Assistant.
And Google, we have
[INAUDIBLE] that
can create almost
human-like voices.
So this is where I
see that maybe soon we
will replace the
actor and actress,
and the computer can
just speak like us.
And another thing I really
like to think of is emotion.
I mentioned earlier, this is a
new way we can create software.
And this is also the time
that we can give software
a personality by using SSML.
And this is where I see that
the direction is going that way.
MELANIE WARRICK: And so
having the emotion to make it
seem more authentic and
more real, and closer
to human-like in a way.
MANDY CHAN: Yeah.
Oh, and one more thing
I want to highlight is--
I mentioned SSML is standard,
and at Google we really think
outside of the box,
that standards are just
common text that different
platforms can use,
such just break
[INAUDIBLE] But we
think outside of the box to
create some customized SSML,
such as Media and Powertech.
This is unique to Action
on Google Platform
and nobody else has that.
And the Media tech allows
you to compose sounds
parallely or sequentially.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
MANDY CHAN: I think I
gave a presentation back
in December 2017 in New York.
I'm not a musician myself,
I would love to be.
But SSML and this whole
voice applications space
allows me to think
like I'm a composer,
I'm a sound designer, that I
can make something really fun.
And people are using that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sound designer
with voice, sound designer
with music, with different
types of various sounds
that you have in the
background type of thing.
MANDY CHAN: Yes, yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: So I know
one of the push backs from I/O
was that there was concerns
about people having Assistant
call up and talk to
them, and whether they'd
be able to recognize that
it's a person or not.
I saw some feedback
that was saying,
we'll make sure it identifies
itself as a computer.
Do you have an opinion
on this realistic voice
being used from the computer?
MANDY CHAN: Like any
new technologies,
it takes time for people
to get used to it.
I think personally, I'm very
open-minded and creative.
So I understand why
people are concerned,
the ethical about turning
a robot into a human.
For me, I'm a big
fan for sci-fi.
I watched the movie,
"Her" and "Star Trek"
is my favorite TV shows.
MELANIE WARRICK: Me too.
MANDY CHAN: So I'm
not against that,
but I can also understand why
people have those concerns.
And this is a really big moment.
Because in the past--
I like to use these example.
The TV, back when you were young
you have to go up to the TV
and turn--
MARK MANDEL: How old
do you think I am?
MANDY CHAN: I am
really bad at telling.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
was going to say,
if you're talking about the days
when we didn't have remotes,
yeah, I remember those days.
MANDY CHAN: Yeah, those
day without the remotes.
You have to go up to the
TV and turn on the knob.
And then we have remotes--
MELANIE WARRICK: And
that was a luxury.
MANDY CHAN: Yes.
And now we don't
even need to have
any physical button and
remote, we can use our voice.
So this is really a
big, big time for us.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
Agreed.
MARK MANDEL: So when
am I going to be
able to walk into my house and
be like, "Turn on the lights"
and everything will work?
And I'll be like,
"Start dinner."
MANDY CHAN: You can do it
now with the lights part.
The dinner part,
I'm not quite sure.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We're not there yet.
But you might be able to
talk to your Assistant
like they're your buddy.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: I think there's
some examples of that out there
actually.
MARK MANDEL: Who
can talk back to me?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So you
mentioned this actually
a little bit before
where you were talking
about Google Assistant
and then also
the fact that you could do
voice actions on the phone.
Do you see any difference
between those two, or at least
even how they're used or
just that whole environment?
MANDY CHAN: Yes.
So building application
for Action on Google Home
specifically, there's no screen.
And when we build
voice applications
we really have to think about
the dialogue, the conversation.
It's like you are
a script writer.
But when you build for mobile
apps or web developments
you don't need to think about
all this storytelling, how
you interact with
another smart assistant.
And another thing
is SSML, of course.
And basically, the UX and UI--
I like to think that
the conversation flow is
like the user
interface, but SSML
is like the user experience.
Because who are you talking to?
The personality
that you're creating
for your voice applications.
And one additional point about
building voice application.
Why is that so different?
Everything is top level.
At any point of the
dialogue you have
with the assistant you don't
need to click the mobile
or with the browser the
next page or going back
to previous page.
You can ask anything,
say anything
at any point of the time.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
We talked a little bit already
about resources and where
people can learn more.
But do you have any
other favorite resources
or recommendations,
especially for people
who are interested
in working with SSML?
MANDY CHAN: Definitely
play around with the Action
on Google console,
the simulator.
And use my library, of course.
MARK MANDEL: Of course.
[LAUGHTER]
We'll put a link to
that in the show notes.
MELANIE WARRICK: But of course.
Are you going to be
speaking anywhere soon?
Doing any demos soon
somewhere else outside of I/O?
MANDY CHAN: I was a
speaker at Grace Hopper
last year talking
about my open-source.
And this year I am continuing
the partnership with Systers.
So Systers is a branch
under Anita Borg.
And Anita Borg and Syster
are the organization
who create the once a year,
the largest woman engineer
conference, Grace Hopper.
So on June 21st and July 31st
I am partnering with the Syster
community to do two online
workshops to teach more women
how to build Action on Google.
So we will share the link
on the website again.
And all this we saw is about
how to build your first Action
on Google.
Everything will be shared
on the website, right?
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I
thought of just one
thing I wanted to ask you, too.
We've seen really
cool examples--
I'm just thinking
around I/O and stuff--
where people do voice actions
where there's context.
So a follow-up question--
I might be like,
"So tell me more
about this particular
sports game."
And then I'll say something
like, "Who was the top player?"
And it knows that the context
is the original-- that sports
game.
You like it how I
use sports game?
Is there anything
inside Actions on Google
or that ecosystem that
handles that kind of thing
to make that a bit easier maybe?
MANDY CHAN: Yes, there's a
game where Dialogflow sharing.
So they have a lot of
interesting and powerful
concepts when it
comes to building
a conversational experience.
And in fact, the concept
is called Context.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
MANDY CHAN: Yes.
So you're right that when
we use voice application,
it will be nice
that they don't have
to keep asking you
what are the artists
that you just played the music.
If you listen to one
song and you want to say,
"More", the assistant knows that
you already chose John Legend.
And when you say,
"Play more," it
will just play more of
John Legend's music.
And that concept
is called Context.
And another interesting
concept is called Lifespan
that Dialogflow provides.
And I like to describe
lifespan like us,
we have short-term memory.
In a conversation
there's multiple turns.
Back and forth for five
lifespan means five turns.
If we keep talking about
some random things,
then the lifespan will expire
like our short-term memory.
We can keep talking
about something random
and just lose focus.
So this concept is really
powerful in voice applications
to give Assistant
short-term memory.
MARK MANDEL: That's super cool.
There are so many layers
to just voice conversations
that I've never
even thought about.
Like, you're talking about tone
and intonation and that stuff,
and basically how
the UI can affect
how your conversation happens.
It's super fascinating.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Communication's complex.
And thus, this is why this
problem is not an easy one
to solve, but we've
made a lot of progress.
MANDY CHAN: We've definitely
made lots of progress.
And with the
developers, I think,
that's why we open
up the platforms
and we really want developers
to play around with our platform
and innovate
together with Google.
MELANIE WARRICK:
How progressive.
MANDY CHAN: Like the
open-source concept.
Right?
More people contribute, the
better the technology becomes.
Same thing for voice space.
MELANIE WARRICK: What languages
do we work with right now
in terms of Action on Google?
MANDY CHAN: We have
many, many languages.
I can't even recall.
I think we have 16 languages.
MARK MANDEL: And by language, do
you mean programming language?
Or do you mean voice language?
Just to be clear.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good question.
MANDY CHAN: So
programming language--
in terms of
programming language,
right now our client library
is written in Node.js.
But in terms of common knowledge
that the Google Assistant
is available, I need to go back
and look at how many countries.
But I think it's available--
there's 16 languages.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
MARK MANDEL: We'll have a
link that will check that.
That's OK.
MELANIE WARRICK: We don't have
to know it right this minute.
But yeah, that's great.
That's good to know.
Well, cool.
MARK MANDEL: Before we wrap
up-- we are running out of time
just a smidge.
It's been great.
Is there anything else you want
to make sure gets mentioned
or you plug?
MANDY CHAN: Wait, wait.
I think I need to show this.
This is really maximizing
the use of SSML
and all this sound library.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Two
brothers in a van.
[CAR SPEEDING]
And then a meteor hit--
[EXPLOSION]
--and ran as fast as they could
[RUNNING STEPS]
--from giant cat monsters.
[ANIMAL GROWLING]
And then a giant tornado came.
[STORM NOISES]
And that's when things got
knocked into 12th gear.
[TIRES SCREECHING]
MANDY CHAN: So this is how you
can use SSML to create a story.
It's great for building
actions for kids, for games,
for party games--
anything like that.
SSML is powerful and
the demo that I just
showed you is really
maximizing the usage of SSML.
And our team actually
wrote a blog post.
It's called, Advanced SSML for
Action on Google on Medium.
So feel free to look that up.
Definitely go to Action on
Google documentation page.
And also, we recently have a
new conversation design page.
So I think I mentioned earlier
that this space is different,
that you need to write
before you even code.
You need to write the
dialogue before you code.
So it's good practice that--
if you have a conversation
designer, great.
If you don't, you can still go
to our conversation new design
website to learn about
the best practice.
Many things can go wrong
in our voice applications.
And in voice, there's no errors.
So go to the website
and learn about how
you can create the best possible
experience for your users.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
Well, thank you.
We really appreciate you coming
on, Mandy, and telling us
all about Actions on Google.
Thank you so much.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
thanks so much.
MANDY CHAN: I had fun.
I had fun demoing
the applications.
And this is really the
space I enjoy so much.
I don't consider
myself I'm working.
I'm considering myself
having fun right now,
and sharing my passions
and inspire more developers
to build on Action on Google.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's wonderful.
MANDY CHAN: And
join me on June 21st
if you ever want to learn how
to build Action on Google.
It's online virtual web shop.
You can sit at home and
learn how to build action.
MARK MANDEL: Ah, fantastic.
MANDY CHAN: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
thank you very much.
MANDY CHAN: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you, again, Mandy.
Really appreciate you
coming on the podcast
and telling us all
about Actions on Google
and getting to play
around with sounds.
I like playing
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
sounds are great.
MELANIE WARRICK: They are.
So does our editors.
Our editors like
sounds, as well.
[MACHINE WHISTLING]
Well, OK, Mark, "I want
to push a Docker image
to Google Container
Registry via Docker push.
So how can I do that so I don't
have to use gcloud Docker --
push every time?"
MARK MANDEL: Well, that's an
excellent question, Mandy.
[HONK]
Mandy.
[MELANIE LAUGHS]
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
right, I'm Mandy.
MARK MANDEL: You're Mandy.
Well, that's an excellent
question, Melanie.
I'm so glad that you
asked the question
that I asked you to ask.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's very convenient
how we worked that out.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
So I wanted to talk about
this for a couple of reasons.
One of which is, sometimes
it's just easier or more
ideal to simply say,
hey, Docker push,
rather than using the gcloud
command to do some stuff,
maybe CI pipelines,
that kind of stuff.
But the other side of
this is actually also
some things around
deprecation, as well.
We'll start at the top level.
So if you want to
simply be able to say,
Docker push or Docker pull
from a Container Registry using
your gcloud
authentication, there's
a command you can run called
gcloud auth configure-docker
And what that will do is
that'll set up some handlers,
add some credential helpers
within your Docker credentials,
and set things up basically
so it's essentially
a seamless process.
This is the preferred way.
We strongly recommend
that you use
this method whenever possible.
It provides secure
short-lived access
to your project resources--
if a read the documentation.
And so basically
that is the way.
So if you ever find
that you're having
issues with, say, gcloud
Docker for any reason,
use this instead.
It's definitely much better.
But it's worth noting
then, for this very reason,
that gcloud Docker is
currently only recommended
for Docker client versions
older than 1.13, which
don't support the use
of credential helpers
or anything like that.
So it's worth noting that
I've seen people try and use
gcloud Docker with newer
versions of Docker,
and sometimes it didn't work
and people get confused,
and that kind of stuff.
So if you're on a new
version of Docker use
the credential helpers
gcloud auth configure-docker,
and that'll make your
lives all that easier.
It's worth noting,
if you really,
really, really, really,
really, really, really, really,
don't want to use that for
some weird reason or you want
to set up individual
short-lived tokens just
for a very short period,
you can do that as well.
We'll link to it in
the documentation.
There's an advanced
authentication thing--
you can still do that
yourself if you need to.
But generally speaking, use
gcloud auth configure-docker
and you are good to go.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
All right, Mark,
you going anywhere,
speaking anywhere anytime soon?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
[MELANIE LAUGHS]
So yes, I am speaking.
So I'll be speaking at the
Kubernetes San Francisco
meet-up on the 14th of June,
giving a little demo of Agones
and talking about that.
I'll also be talking at
the Kubernetes community
meeting on the 21st.
That's an online meeting.
I'll put some details for
that also in the show notes.
So I'll also be talking
about Agones, as well.
What are you up to?
MELANIE WARRICK: I am speaking
at a joint Women in Machine
Learning and Data Science
and PyLadies event, that's
titled "Paths to Data
Science," on June 26.
And I will also be speaking
at AI4ALL on June 28th.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Looking forward to it.
Mark, I think that's it
for us for this week.
That was fun.
MARK MANDEL: It was good.
MELANIE WARRICK: That was
really fun with Mandy.
I'm glad we got a chance
to finally do that,
because I know you've been
wanting to do that for a while.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I agree.
There were some really
great little sound bites
and fun sound things
that happened there.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sound bits
and bytes and all the things.
Yeah, we got some fun
stuff out of that.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Thanks, Melanie, for joining
me for yet another week
on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: And thanks,
everyone, for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
MANDY CHAN: (INTO SIMULATOR)
Add a synthesizer.
[SYNTHESIZER MUSIC PLAYING]
And I can add more layer.
(INTO SIMULATOR) Add
a relaxing guitar.
[SYNTHESIZER AND GUITAR MUSIC
PLAYING]
Add a drum machine.
[SYNTHESIZER AND GUITAR WITH
DRUM MUSIC PLAYING]
Play it underwater.
[SAME MUSIC PLAYING AMONG WAVES]
Yeah, there's all
kinds of fun songs.
You can add many, many layers.
That's why I feel like I'm
a musician or a composer
just by playing with
voice applications.
[MUSIC CONTINUES]